greets everyone I'm Alana and welcome it
to my channel as part of Nintendo's 78th
annual general meeting of shareholders
the company said something a little bit
concerning apparently in the future they
are planning to bring it 20 to 30 indie
games or Ninh Dee's as they call them to
the Nintendo switch every single week
that's a lot and there's a lot to unpack
here so let's get to it so we already
know that Nintendo has been working
really hard to support and get the
support of Indies after not doing such a
great job of that on previous platforms
at least according to developers things
have changed so much with Damon Baker
ahead of publisher and developer
relations for the Ninh DS program
talking about how creative and unique
indie games are and how excited he was
to showcase Indies that resonate well
with the Nintendo audience on the switch
just the week after it launched before
it even came out they targeted
relationships with any publishers like
team 17 chuckle fish 2 vulva Double Fine
role Fury it's now the thing is out and
some Indies have sold even millions of
copies on switch some indie devs have
come forward saying that the switch
version of their game is the most
successful version of their game even
for games that are several years old
some games like Wonder Boy the Dragons
trap have outsold all other platform
versions combined including Xbox one ps4
PC all of which have a higher install
base than the switch does so basically
right now it's a great place for Indies
to be and it seems like a whole lot of
gamers out there are demanding switch
versions of games sometimes even myself
included I never would have thought that
I'd buy Skyrim again for the thousandth
time but here I am obviously Skyrim is
an indie game but the point remains
there's a lot of demand for games to be
on switch and gamers might even buy
games they've already bought before just
for the appeal of that console in fact
I've even seen youtubers say that if
devs aren't bringing their games to
switch that basically murdering their
games and it's the best place to be and
you're an idiot if you don't bring it to
switch and they will never buy it if you
don't bring it to switch speaking of
which the AHA parts of the community who
complained that there aren't enough
games on the switch at all even
including the seven or so nin DS that
currently release every week
so just everyone from every angle is
basically yelling put your game on the
switch you idiot
develop is a seeing with stuff and being
like well holy pants
teri people really want to play our game
on the Nintendo switch so let's listen
to the community and put it on this
Nintendo bringing more games to switch
is seemingly an Thera got a positive for
everyone but there's a catch and we'll
get to that
so Nintendo makes money by hosting these
games on their each shop the Andes make
money because you know the games of
selling and game is keep asking for more
games to be on the switch so when you're
holding a shareholder meeting for people
who care about how profitable your
company is it makes sense that you would
put one and one and one together and say
yes obviously we're bringing more indie
games to the switch the sales support
that logic to switch user base is very
active and hungry for more indie titles
or third-party titles they can play
between major first party Nintendo
releases so yes everyone's been asking
for it and indicating that it works with
previous sales stats but 20 to 30 games
a week is a pretty big jump and we've
been burned before over 7,000 games were
released on Steam in 2017 and that rate
just keeps growing with so many games
being released every single day new
titles get almost no time to shine and
develop this who can't afford
traditional marketing struggle to find
an audience and make a profit steam can
in a lot of cases be a place where yo
any game or even no indie studio goes to
die because you're released on a day
with way too much other [ __ ] that
applies to most days games from indie
devs used to have a pretty good chance
of finding a spot on the front page and
staying there for a few days but now
that setup is much less friendly things
are updated way too quickly there are
too many other games to compete with I
mean you get the idea but basically
discoverability becomes an issue and I
kind of think that's already a little
bit of a problem on the switch back when
the switch actually came out the CEO of
image and form games who you might know
for steamworld dig 2 came out and said
it's really not that indie friendly on
Steam anymore it's not even publisher
friendly it started to resemble the App
Store in a way you have so many titles
that almost by definition it's not indie
friendly on the App Store you have a
hundred new games coming out every day
maybe
there are a hundred games coming out to
the switch in a year you're almost
guaranteed so much more visibility
around the same time that the CEO of
image inform said that Damon Baker said
the way we're looking at the switch is
this is a complementary platform if it's
on Steam then there's no reason why it
shouldn't be on Nintendo switch as well
which unless his goals have changed
implies to me that maybe at some point
in the future Nintendo will want to have
more than twenty to thirty games so to
even be able to really accommodate these
twenty to thirty games first up the
eShop needs to change and I would hope
that Nintendo would change the eShop
before adding all these extra games in
no joke when you type in Mao in the
store you'd think the first thing that
would come up is Mario
it's a Nintendo console but no literally
the word marijuana comes up before Mario
does clearly there are some issues here
and at least steam is kind of designed
for discovery where the eShop barely
even shows 30 games total how is it
going to manage 30 games per week the
switch almost already feels like the
steam store just because of the way that
it's laid out and adding more games is
going to make that a whole lot worse
discoverability needs to be worked on
organization needs to be worked on most
important to me though is quality
control if you're going to be bringing
1,500 extra games each year to the
Nintendo switch
they need to be curated so the store
doesn't just get filled with shovel one
even the indie devs are worried about
the same thing
Klaus from zoink Games said I wanted to
be curated somehow because I don't want
to be stuck that's the problem with
Steam right now it doesn't matter if
there are so many uses on Steam because
if you can't reach any of them with all
the noise it doesn't matter the
widespread indie success that we've seen
on the switch is also encouraging other
Studios like joint games to flock to
that platform quality studios if you're
actively trying to release 30 games a
week that visibility is going to drop
and the interest from those quality
Studios is going to drop with it so it's
not just about the risk of shovelware
and of bad games coming to the switch
and it being hard to filter through them
there's also the risk of quality Studios
no longer having as much interest in the
platform so it's not like it's just more
bad games based on
percentage it's also literally that good
games might not want to be there anymore
look if this is handled incorrectly and
I'm not saying it will be antenna has
repeatedly set in the pause that they're
aware of the importance of staggering
releases and avoiding flooding them
marketplace so they know these issues
but if it is handled incorrectly it
would just suck for everyone it's bad
for switch owners who are eager to try
new and unique titles in a store that's
weighed down by low-quality ones I mean
I just want to say I think the last
thing intento needs right now is to
become anything like steam I'm hoping
that when Nintendo's former president
current advisor Kimi Shima said
increasing the number of people who make
games to be played on Nintendo platforms
is also very important for growing our
business that he wasn't meeting their
business as a digital distribution
service that takes a cut of every game
released on the platform and thus wants
quality quantity of equality quality
would be good no quantity over quality I
get that money is money and then it's
hard not to look at steam with like big
ol hot eyes and just be like oh look at
the money printing machine but it is a
little funny that Gabe Newell said
recently that he's jealous of Nintendo
right now or at least before they made
this announcement I don't know what he
thinks right now I don't know I do trust
in tender to handle this correctly but
this is also giving me kind of
flashbacks to the great video game crash
of 1983 where there was just way too
much market saturation and revenues
dropped by like 97% wasn't actually
alive then so it's not a real flashback
and I know this isn't as Extreme as that
but it's a bold move either way and I
think we really shouldn't underestimate
the potential impact that it could have
but of course let me know what you guys
think that is it from me today everyone
huge thanks to everyone who's supporting
me on patreon for my last month of
patreon I hope you enjoyed this video
and I will see you guys next time